organized that tell Hansen that he will
he will get a chance to play Hikaru if
he wants it a car doesn't back away from
a challenge challenges back away from
him all right I'll stop the Chuck Norris
jokes I was just having fun okay just
having fun all right well now Eric
Hanson and Hikaru can have their fun and
make it happen we are now seeing two
very strong grandmasters decaro of
course being the the one of the
strongest in the world Eric Hanson young
talented Grandmaster out of Canada I've
known Eric since he was a kid
not a certain little kid because he was
never little always a really tall guy
but I've known Eric since he was younger
one of the top players from Canada now
Eric currently lives I believe in the
Netherlands he can confirm that four
people in the chat but pretty sure he
does a good start for white not
necessarily my favorite kind of Sicilian
for Eric but he's gonna do his best to
create queenside counter play here to
make up for the dominant center white
house Bishop to c5 was threatened so
mcaro says okay I'm gonna back that
thing up he five is a move that he would
like to play now but maybe maybe Hansen
can put the knight on d5 and Carlos says
I'm not really sure I care I'll trade
and then play King to be one is that
what do you think he's gonna play Knight
to e4 and head to a position where he
doesn't care about the dark square
bishop no he goes for the first idea
take some place King to be one probably
even b3 is okay here yeah and then he
can work on kicking back the the white
piece the black pieces this is a little
bit tricky though Hansen definitely
bring in the heat definitely bring in
the heat here against a Karl
Nakara plays a three my guess is he can
meet b4 with Queen takes a six that's
kind of key that's kind of critical as
far as making a3 work because b4 is a
very dangerous threat to try to pry open
the the maining attack and so and so
there you go so apparently Eric had
stepped away before so he apologizes for
that but happy to be here playing now
black is definitely doing okay here it's
because if black doesn't get that right
the counterplay that he wants white is
still going to be positionally better in
the long run because of the weaknesses
along the D file this ePHI pawn is is
making a critical point on d6 which
leaves the decent the d7 pawn backward
so even a move like oh maybe not Queen
to d2 because then b4 well Hanson is
gonna play what I'm what I'm trying to
get to is this game is gonna become one
where either Eric gets a winning attack
against white or Hikaru is gonna win the
game long-term or at least be better in
the endgame if you can simplify the
position and take away some of blacks
pressure but this is definitely one of
the strongest games we've had so far
obviously glass sides taking a car down
still the mystery man who played a super
high quality game against a car earlier
if you're just joining us but other than
that we've seen a car will be pretty
dominant not really play anybody who
could give him a run for the old money
but now he's probably calculating a few
things along with a four as well as b3
he decides on b3 first and this is it
this is how this is how this is how the
West was won right here this is how
champions are made this is how
unnecessary metaphors come into play on
a chef show you know I'm talking about
b3 is played to okay and Eric says I'm
going for he's probably gonna play
Brooks III immediately which looks
really strong I don't think that this is
gonna work out super well for her car Oh
actually I think that he's uh he's not
gonna be able to hold this position
although amazingly he can actually get
away with Bishop to b2 Wow because the
pawn can't take because it's pin to the
Queen this is still a ton of pressure
for black but if a car can just
sacrifice this pawn and prevent this
from happening
he'll be in really good shape he's gonna
play a four here for sure and if a four
Queen takes then he can even play Queen
takes d7 offer a queen straight and meat
queen a three with a move like Brooke to
B to d2 and I don't see a way for Hanson
to win actually so as usual I was wrong
wait Queen takes d7 could be
rook takes B 2 and then Queen a3 check
and then Queen to b3 check which would
actually be a perpetual so a Carlos says
no no no right he goes with dick emblem
it Dikembe Mutombo on that and says get
out of my house right Queen to c2 now
he's threatening nothing really no he is
threatening he's betting rook to d3 and
that's no fun he's also making Eric
realized that time is of the essence now
Queen a3 is played but it doesn't do
enough rook takes d7 the move now is
probably Bishop b4 which has a dual
threat rook to d3 to trade everything
wait rook to d1 is also possible here
but I would probably play Bishop before
if I was Hikaru hit age 7 threatened
rook to d3 and akaru is gonna be on his
way to winning and surviving what was a
really vicious attack from Eric Hansen
should be on his way to winning this
game now I don't know why you didn't
play Bishop before the move before there
must have been some threat with rook to
c8 I wasn't saying to do to deflect the
Queen and mate so a Caro saw more than I
did big surprise right and avoids the
the concrete threats from black and he's
creating a situation now where where
he's defended everything and I think
just rook c8 and h5 is coming and Eric's
gonna lose on time here and didn't have
enough wow that was an exciting game
that was exciting maybe they'll play
again rematch
all right I don't know if they're gonna
rematch oat they are uh-huh
that wasn't enough one was not enough
when you see that kind of quality just
right there that was a really exciting
game and I almost have to have to shame
myself for thinking that Eric was gonna
win that attack right the champ was not
gonna go do I told the guard I said you
can finish with Eric and then play me if
you want he's like all right fine I'll
pound you too like thanks buddy
you know all right well here we have a
McCutcheon French which is uh ooh
the Bishop to c1 McCutcheon French I
don't know this line I always get
excited when grandmasters play things I
don't know like I'm gonna learn
something as if it would ever make a
difference to make me a better chess
player let's be honest and you're beyond
help okay but I don't really know this
line other than the fact it's a typical
French and black is gonna play for the
typical strategical ideas c5 and White's
gonna want to defend the center so that
he can focus on an attack these be six
lines with Bishop a six are also always
interesting because they're so
positionally sound for for black play
Cara was just trying to get rid of what
is the bad Bishop for the good bishop
then he can slowly reorganize and do
plans that are all based around the
typical French approach getting counter
play on the Queen side trying to
undermine white center with the moves
like c5 that's exactly what he's doing
here I really like the way he's playing
this I do not think this is a McCutchin
French dawn perfectly for for Eric and
and I really like this to it what a car
is doing is by putting the King on the
Queen side it makes White's pieces feel
more and more misplaced because they're
not going to be able to bring an attack
as quickly over here as he'll probably
be able to do over here if I'm in carro
I probably look to play rook g8 and then
advance these pawns team to b7 is a
prophylactic move first makes sense and
again he once he wants to bring the rook
to g8 and then play g5 and open things
up so that he can get a an attack
against White's King
thank you everybody who joined us today
not saying that because we're saying our
good-byes yet we still got some exciting
games here but if you are just joining
us where have you been
you clearly wasted your Saturday because
the most exciting thing in the world was
happening right here for those of you
who've been with us thank you for being
with us and I hope you enjoyed hope you
subscribed to our channel you can also
subscribe everywhere else YouTube /
chess
we got twitch we got faith we got
everything you know things go do it
alright what's gonna happen now the deep
one's gonna come under fire and I'm
that's what I'm thinking about it
understand the way hikaru played it cuz
now he's gonna lose that pawn he's
probably still totally fine in the end
game honestly it's still a position
where we might even prefer black because
if takes takes black and play like b5
and critically just like trap those
pawns on the dark squares where even if
you consider that all of whites pawns
are sort of stuck it's hard to believe
you'd be any worse I play I play for b5
and then okay well he finds a way to not
lose the pawn what I wanted was b5
taking everything trade rooks and then B
winning in the endgame with with the
King entering on the light squares I
actually think my idea was even better
in this rare case I can save this game
just so i can show it karo the really
awesome idea I found so he can be like
yeah Danny what's your point right but I
won't do that
I won't do that because I'm better than
that let's be honest I'm not above that
at all I'm gonna save this game and then
show a car with the idea and see if he
tells me what's wrong with it
ha4 but a car was just winning in this
endgame if he can just get the king out
because white spawns are so much easier
to target can he play Bishop to c5 and
offered the trade he could but he may
not be winning no matter what because if
Bishop c5 White's just gonna play a4 if
Bishop c5 takes takes White would lose
because the King would enter too fast
but he's not probably a car was not
gonna be able to win this endgame unless
there's something about this that I'm
just not understanding he can
the king over and try for g6 and make a
trade but I don't think it's possible to
dislodge white on the corner you know
you can give Jack and now he's gonna
play g6 no he must have prevent a five
probably probably this game will end in
a draw
unless a Caro decides he wants to win on
time against Eric which is totally
reasonable creating a form of xiguan oh
but now he's gonna go after that pawn
after King g3 then he gets something
like h5 and H 4 I guess so he can play
h4 now and then take and after Bishop
here to guard the pawn now white is
gonna lose because I think at Bishop to
d4 I think black can start to push him
back and create a way in with the King
ah
Hanson sees that coming and he's gonna
try to keep the King there as best he
can the point is if this King retreats
then black will create an avenue for the
King to get in so white has to try to
keep this King out hey Carlos go ok he's
gonna give this check and then he's
gonna try to get in and Carla's goal is
gonna be to try to create a position
where he can improve the King and get in
and he's doing just that really
impressive technique here once again I
show why I am not in their league or
class at all by saying that a car was
not gonna be alone in this game
Dany once again doubted cards not that I
doubted Carter I was talking about the
position generally okay and this is now
just easily winning he's gonna be able
to even give up the bishop for this pawn
unless it karma made a huge blunder
there no Oh smashing
ouch town ouch town population white bro
look at that he pins the pawn to the
bishop and it's over
if b7 you take the bishop if the bishop
moves you take the pawn if white just
sits there Blacks just gonna advance the
pawn and Queen I would have played a
four here and just gone in for some
crazy race where I'm probably winning
anyway but I would have made it a lot
crazier Bishop to d4 is that's super GM
stuff right there alright look at this
this is exciting
two things that make me more excited
than sacrificing a b2 pawn to the Queen
and neither is appropriate
the show what is going on right now is
probably a 3 and B 4 although you do
have to be a little careful of B 5 of
your high carb
Nakara is currently up to nothing in
this little mini match with Eric Hansen
he's not shying away from a challenge
I'm so glad that one strong GM showed up
to challenge a car today right besides
me ok and Carl's just sacrificing the
b-pawn holy shenanigans and then C 4 is
a B 3 check 92 94 a little bit nasty
that's nasty he's just wait wait he's
just winning a piece here I think a Carl
just blundered away this game that was
weird
Carl doesn't normally make blunders out
of the opening so he just clearly
miscalculated that but he's not gonna
give up because this game is gonna be
something that still has a little bit of
technique required from mr. Eric Hanson
and Nikora was gonna see if he can win
after blundering a piece out of the
opening we can back up and take a look
at that but I think a Carl just
blundered with this move this whole idea
with 9 a 4 and C 3 created this dynamic
where the knight was being threatened to
be trapped and I think he just you know
even the best players will make mistakes
well see if he can come back he's down
you know both on time I guess he's up a
little bit on time but he's down enough
on the board that you know he would
definitely lose in a classical game but
this is blitz not for the faint-hearted
he's gonna play up for he wants to play
up for anyway and try to create an
attack and Danny and some of your
previous games you've made a mention
that you might make a plan for GM I
would love to go for a GM but right now
we're busy building the chest the best
chess website and company in the world
in chess comm you know I do want to go
try to improve my chess skills again at
some point I'm still young I'm not 30
yet so hopefully that that's ok
the way that I'm highlighting and
drawing things is simply by
right-clicking on the board when you're
observing any boy
yourself on chess comm you to have the
ability to make a chess video you can
draw arrows and highlight squares and
pretty much do whatever you want on a
board if you are analyzing a game if
you're observing someone's game you can
do all the same things I'm doing so it
just use the right click that's all I'm
doing
nothing nothing fancy schmancy hey
Carter should lose this game
he just didn't quite get enough for the
compensate he tried to create some
controversy after blundering his piece
but really he was sort of outmatched
there blundering up he's that early
against a strong player like this really
hard to come back from that you know and
I don't think a car will will be an
exception to that in this game he may
decide to play one more against Erik as
a card doesn't like to go on a loss or
he may decide to move on to me and just
seek his revenge by you know taking
advantage of you know dad disciplines
the kid kid goes and you know was mean
to the dog right so car was gonna go
take it out on me but I'm not endorsing
that behavior by the way I'm saying
that's a problem but don't get all
political on me like hey you just
endorsed being mean to dogs and people
that's not what I did but I was just
saying that that's something that
sometimes happens in our society and I
don't approve of it that's what I was
saying get over it
well a car was is creating some
controversy if he wins this game I just
like you know it's gonna be like oh
we're not worthy from Wayne's World I'm
serious I'm just gonna go nuts I'm just
gonna go nuts yeah I don't think he's
gonna be able to hold on it's just it's
just too much to hold on in this
position he's been down a piece for like
you know 70 moves that's an exaggeration
I'm good at that okay if Bishop c80
takes here though okay Bishop comes to a
4 but probably the karo should take a 5
first noe decides to take a 7 first off
but what's what's Eric Hanson trying to
do he's trying to bring the bishop to f3
which will lead to bringing the Bishop
to e2 okay and Caro is gonna try to
prevent this from happening by going to
get a queen that would be a problem that
would be a problem for Eric if a Cara
went and got a queen but now we can take
a five I think or Bishop e5 and now
who's winning
probably not Eric Hansen anymore I don't
know that that was the best way for a
car to do it I thought maybe you should
have just taken on them
f5 actually but he didn't he's still
making something magical happen here
that's for sure unless he gets mated
they don't know I don't know what's
happening I have no idea what's going on
here if you play XIII though but he just
takes it Carl comes back and wins the
game after blundering a piece out of the
opening we're not worthy
we're not worthy we're not we're
seriously right I mean that was
ridiculous I was totally ridiculous
American for ridiculous man
that was awesome hey Carl came back and
won that game holy shenanigans and you
know what a car just did he just brought
it in for the real thing by challenging
me are you guys ready for the climax of
this show bring it on
Danny show it Carl what it's all about
oh I'm gonna show you baby girl
I'm gonna show you what it's all about
don't think I won't play this way I'll
play the McCutchin with you all day
sister hey Carl I'm gonna bring it and
dude you're about to get smashed you
can't play this way against me I
invented this opening I invented it just
in my spare time on chess calm it's just
something I do I just invent openings
all the time don't even worry about it
this about - it's about to be Broughton
right now wait can you play this way can
you bring the noise in the funk like
this I don't know but you're doing it
you're doing it I don't even like it I'm
not even sure I care though bring it on
Donkey Kong I'm gonna play there uh-oh
can I not defend that pawn probably I
can't but I probably don't even care I'm
probably about to rock his world I am
probably about to rock his world he's
got nothing
jingling jingling say what correctly g7
if I take f7 he takes rook up three
check King moves check a ruski boom town
yeah you better run with that King you
better run with that King kitten Bishop
d2 queenie for czech takes knight takes
probably not enough for me to get
anything have to be a little more
careful than that yeah right there must
be something here for me right it feels
good I don't know let's just say this
isn't my first rodeo
this ain't my first Blitz game all right
but dunk dunk like I said but a car
winning that last game was seriously a
Wayne's World we're not worthy moment
that was awesome
the Karl blunt heard a piece against
Eric and came back and won and I was
once again I feel like I should never
doubt a carro again I feel like I should
be shamed into some sort of you know
confessional so I feel right now
you know can he really do that what is
he doing I never know what he's doing I
feel like he doesn't even know what he's
doing I'm just gonna go for things I'm
gonna go for crazy town and I'm probably
gonna win this game
I have to go for this and if I get made
it I get made it so be it if I get made
it I get made it it wouldn't be the
first time and I did not mean that in
any sort of inappropriate way I meant it
purely in like I blues chess games like
literally losing chess games is what I
do for a living that's all I do I lose
chess games some people all they do is
win all I do is lose all I do is lose
lose lose lose all I do is lose all
right am I about to always playing clean
b1 check oh right
crikey absolutely you know the
difference between Australia and New
Guinea accent C absolutely Islam
Australian they long gate there right
the outback no ice right New Zealand is
a little more a little more cut off
talking like this could I write good eye
that's how you know a New Zealand versus
Australian you just learned something so
at least you can leave you're saying I
learned something about accents from
Danny today you're welcome
at least you can leave saying you
learned something
what are you doing a car oh you always
beat me and it's not fair even when I
talked tons of trash and almost beat you
where's the mate
where's the mate show me the mate I just
might Cuba Gooding jr. on you show me
the money is there a mate oh there is a
mate Ali
Nakara wins again then we'll all that
trash talk that was just that that was
just kidding man I was totally just
kidding that was amazing
I mean she we played best of three let's
play one more best of three one more all
right
yo-yo all right
you'll get over here you'll forget about
it I'm gonna take him down right here
what wait what's going on
abort okay rematch that was super weird
my board got frozen
that was weird and not healthy that was
super weird what what are you doing I
never know what you're doing
you want to play the bloomenfeld Oh
yeah oh yeah that's like people who know
just like oh snap y'all just got real
things that just went down wait can you
do this what are you doing
Caro I don't know what you're doing stop
it
you're doing things I don't know what
you're doing aah oh snap mm-hmm not my
first time seeing that tactic oh it's
not my first time blundering either oops
if I take you at Bishop e4 oops that was
bad as that I was supposed to play by
the way that tactic does occur in games
I should have been a little more patient
I should have played you 5 her castle or
something first so I should have known
that us you know the number 3 player in
the world is not blundering that common
Knight takes d5 tactic out of the
opening that's what I should have done
but I didn't
some people's hindsight vision is 20/20
the only vision I have is hindsight okay
so I didn't get to choose if it's 20/20
or not I'm just constantly regretting my
decisions
all right don't you try that on you know
I feel like Zach Galifianakis here once
you try being you know fat and smelling
like Doritos and then try to make it in
Hollywood you know I'm talking about um
this is just not good I don't think I'm
losing yet though so I'm just gonna make
moves I I don't know what's going on
here I'm just trying to survive the
story of my life you know uh what are
you doing what are you doing
I can't recover from my blunder
you can't recover from my blunder okay
complete Bishop f6 you can take and then
I'll take and then you can move and I
get like a couple of pieces for them I
got a rook for cone pieces I want to
take here and if he takes a six sacks F
sack of three but if I take he can take
on g5 so my trick doesn't work
darn it unless there's something else
nasty I can do BAM slam jam cram jam
slam wham check a ruski I got nothing I
gotta go for this I wanted to take he's
six at Caro if you would have let me win
I would have done it but you wouldn't
let me win so instead I have to go for
this worse end game where I get a rook
for two pieces I know I'm aware of how
good your position is we all get it we
know how much better you are than Danny
all right I'm gonna bring that rook to
e8 though oh you better believe it I'm a
shake and bake I'll let you sack that
Queen
go for it kitten you want to sack that
Queen sack that Queen you'll sack that
Queen I'm gonna go get the a pawn now oh
I should play Queen a6 that was silly of
me
are you gonna make me that would be very
polite yeah but you better have made you
better have made or you're gonna regret
it
I've only got 30 seconds though time to
uh time to cowboy up as they say in the
PG version of that saying you know time
to cowboy up or shut up right you know
what I'm talking about do I have
anything here I think I do I have some
kind of compensation if you plays Brooks
e2i b3 and then he's losing the Queen is
actually gonna hold her own if I had
time on the clock but I don't have any
time excuses Danny we get it we know
you're making excuses yeah I am oh snap
town if I play King there he wins I have
to go this way
oh if I had played by the way if I'd
play King here he would have played 95
check and after everything takes he has
rook there and if I had played King here
maybe King of five would have been
something worthy but he karo shows why
he is the man by forking me that would
have been sweet I'm just gonna resign to
show everybody how a car would have won
if I had played King to h7 with a
brilliant night Shaq and then he mates
me here I mean I can give up the Queen
but I'm awesome wowzers wowzers wowzers
a Cara Nakamura once again once again
amazing we love it all right let's bring
a car back on right before we end the
show and talk a little bit about about
what happened there let's um let's bring
him back on just for a momento just for
a mento a momento dude that really hurt
that really hurt in a good way which is
weird you know I know totally and I was
like what was I thinking that hit Karl
didn't the car didn't see that idea of
course she knew what was going that was
just totally yeah car was talking about
my Knight takes d5 which for everyone
here is an idea that black can play for
and this little you know blind of the
Blumenfeld but not here and I just
totally got you know excited I got
overly excited you know I was nervous I
was like a giddy little schoolgirl
playing you know I I should know better
no totally that game where you came back
and won against Erick after being down a
piece hashtag we're not worthy that was
amazing
that was awesome dude and I know it was
wild and it was just you doing your best
after you know basically a you know a
blunder in the opening and you and you
came back but that was awesome effort
the crowd went wild for that all right
well a fantastic day you didn't lose a
single game besides the game to glass
ice who we're still looking into if that
is a
you know secret super GM in disguise or
perhaps you know a technological device
that shall not be named but um no but
that was it that was an interesting game
right what was your feeling that game
just was that was a weird game but other
than that I mean really just dominant by
you today awesome stuff yeah got it
sorry yeah David Sanders yeah he played
well and then and then you you ended up
doing what you got to do sometimes in
blitz right yeah
scotch for nights right when he decided
to follow my game with Robson from the
US champ yeah I know it was funny a lot
of people in chat were pointing that out
which is awesome that so many people you
know Falls the US Championship and your
games but right but yeah so that that
game was also a good one
what went wrong in that scotch by the
way if I if I pulled that up pulled up I
mean it was pretty equal the whole way
through I think in general um the
position was okay nevertheless but I
felt that c5 was a positional error once
I gone c4 I think white knee or black
needs to wait until white either place
c5 or white takes on d5 uh-huh because
I'm positioning plate c5 I was able to
go Knight c3 and even though he had a
tactical solution in that instance
normally it's not it's not the best way
of playing right yeah I know in you a
happily sacrifice the exchange there you
were mm-hmm you definitely have probably
only equal but still it's alright it's
definitely reasonable yeah and so so but
the his decision to go to the endgame
obviously getting the double deft pawns
this position is still dynamic enough
where blacks bishop pair can be okay
here absolutely yeah their money in for
Wyatt also puts the knight on g3 or d4
which is uh I think there was a game
Carlotta Moro zai which which had a
similar kind of structure in the night
coming up on g3 and somehow to end up
going to each five at some point right
but for the most part yeah but the two
bishops are pretty strong even though
you's a bad pawn structure okay yeah so
the game with potpie dude obviously the
game with David Sanders he played
extremely well you know the wind by
glass ice as we pointed out but the
games with Eric were what yeah that's
what I was gonna mention the first game
with Eric of course where I think he was
probably winning yeah but we couldn't
quite see it I was I was trying you know
I'll admit that I you know everyone
ridiculed me this is how much they loved
you for for doubting that you were gonna
win but I was saying I was saying it
looks like Eric's attack was really
strong and I wasn't sure if you were
gonna be able to hold on but you did had
you I think once I got a foreigner
probably fine I think he might have been
able to go cleaning for it the right now
instead of rook b8 ah I'm looking at
that someone's like enemy a4 it's very
hard to block to do anything so it's
just you know if difficult so a lot of
play for both sides but it's not not
clear at all if Queen a4 is played do
you maybe try to settle for a draw with
Queen takes d7 and allow him to play
rook takes B to check and and get a
perpetual with Queen yeah maybe I have
to do that once you've done that in the
game though so it's right not to give
away any points yeah you don't you don't
go for draws that we love that okay no
but Queen a for death that's brilliant
actually we didn't I didn't see that I
was looking at this position and
remembering saying the same thing that
as soon as you got a four feeling much
better about your chances and so okay so
there we go everybody that was maybe
Eric's improvement was this move Queen
a4 though then the only other one I told
everyone I would bring up with you was
the the next game where you were black
you uh the one that the what in the end
let's see there was this McCutcheon
endgame where you played yes this one
the son game yeah I mean I Eric actually
played quite well to find this this nice
little idea with b5 uh-huh which was I
mean quite nice because once he gets in
b5 an aid for all the endgame should be
drawn right I'm just a genre rule but
the basically Eric's mistake was he went
f3 which if he doesn't go f3 if he
leaves the pawns on f2 and f4 and just
puts a bishop on e3 and goes king g3 h3
forever it should just be a draw
right showing everybody that as you're
talking yeah so should have been a draw
and it'll move that I was wanted to ask
you about was the idea I saw on in the
position where you decided to play
Brooksie 8 and give up the D pawn for
the c2 pawn I thought that I thought
that maybe you would try to play b5
yourself and give up the D pawn because
if rook T if everything gets traded on
d4 you can play rook to d8 and then
trade rooks and maybe your King comes
from c6 to d5 and c4 and sides also yeah
this is also a pretty interesting idea -
I actually didn't think of that
but yeah it's probably it's probably
okay as well okay so you might have I
thought that I was the only one that
even down a pawn you're probably the
only one who can win that endgame there
if you play b5 but maybe but I'm not so
sure so if I go b5 egos rook d7 shock
rook c7 if he exchanges and then goes
Bishop to e3 for example attacking the
pawn on a 7 okay and then he follows it
up with c4 and accident I think White's
probably quite a bit better
oh no I'm talking about playing B five
instead of rook c8 on Moo 27 and then
rook takes d4 rook takes d4 rook takes
d4 rook da and then everybody gets
traded
yeah actually hmm and maybe maybe just
play the King and Bishop ending where
positionally you've locked down the a3
before months okay I mean I'm just this
was just probably it's probably quite
strong okay well apparently um
apparently Eric was streaming some of
his games with you at the same time I
don't know what his channel is but he
was uh he was trying to get a win
against Hikaru and he was quite bummed
when you were not when you uh you didn't
allow that to happen so good stuff yeah
especially the third game yeah well that
was that was great and coming back from
downed repeats again I told everybody I
said if a car wins this game I'm gonna
go Wayne's World I'm not worthy on this
and so I was like we're not worthy
let's see we had some people ask a
couple questions if let's see if we
could if it karo if you could give one
piece of advice to a player trying to
break trying to get through their
beginning ratings like 900 what's what's
a piece of advice you can give for
beginners chess beginners um I mean I
think the main thing at that level is
just play
as much as you can I mean it has nothing
to do with quality but just play as much
you can cheat basically at that level
what you need to do is you need to
understand the patterns mm-hmm so
tactics but on a simpler level so just
saying like one movement to move
combinations which I think the best way
for that I just play I mean play as much
you can it doesn't matter blitz bullet
whatever just play endlessly so at that
level it's almost quantity over quality
right just the amount of games they're
playing it's about picking up the
patterns I've got it and so that's why
it's very important all right Thank You
Stuart lever for following me on Twitter
and asking that question for a car let's
see we have a another question for a car
oh if and when you eat Oreo cookies how
many are left in the package afterwards
are you an Oreo cookie fan um you know
strange I had some Oreos recently for I
think the first time in like maybe I
don't know 15 years or something um and
it was it was only like four cookies but
I have to say they did not taste
anywhere near as good as they did when I
was younger so maybe I've just lost the
taste for them or something so the
answer would be one if but if I actually
okay
sorry okay thank you thank you for that
really critical question Danny Winn
all right we haven't a game from let's
see German Andre says hey Caro how can
you possibly know so many openings
literally amazing so you want to answer
that I'm sure I mean I think I think I
think there many factors involved I
think the first one is just the changing
landscape of chess these days do two
computer engines in that you have to be
able to play so many different openings
just to keep your opponents off balance
I mean growing up I really only have
like one system against every opening
you know for example my gaming us Eric
the first one I played the or I tried to
play the Grand Prix attack and that's
that's all that I played growing up and
and so you know it's like nestling I the
Grand Prix attack against 45 I only
played the scotch or the Scotch gambit
um and so I only had one variation but
of course when technology started
getting better which was around the
comics 2,300 2,400 I just started adding
a lot of different openings and I think
it's also why at a young age it's
important to experiment because if you
if you reach a certain level it's very
hard to just change because he has so
much confidence in what you studied
growing up that you can't it's not easy
to just decide okay you know what I'm
gonna change and play something
different but having said that I think
you know what one example where it's
quite remarkable is the case of Vladimir
Kramnik we're in 2000 I think it was
maybe 2005 six I can't be exact here he
decided to go from playing 1.d4 to
playing 1.e4 and he had only played d4
his entire life
but he chose to switch it up and I think
because of that he gained a certain
understanding of different structures
that he was not familiar with before
interesting so you feel like changing
openings at different points can be with
that purpose to to try to purposely get
into formations or you know certain
positions where there's different
strategical thinking required than the
normal positions you've been playing
yeah absolutely okay interesting yes so
all right I know uh more of you are
coming in on Twitter and trying to get
more questions we're just gonna take a
couple more than let her car ago it's
been a long day two more one hikaru if
you could if you could play any world
champion in history in a match who would
it be uh any world champion huh
that came kappa blanka kevin white why
kappa blanka uh just because i mean i i
look back at the history of chess i when
i looked the world champions he was the
first one who i think i would say is
probably a grand master level like if
you could bring it back today he would
he would still be a grandmaster and so i
think it'd be very interesting to play
against someone like that just because
he was very strong for his time and he's
obviously way ahead of his time so just
having the armies to see the way that he
thinks the way that he approaches the
game would be really interesting right
okay
awesome great answer one more I'm just
gonna choose one more here we have one
from Andreas Mauricio Emma dro on
Twitter he says Hikaru or no let's say
no I'm reading the wrong one this is we
have a question from a new username that
I will not try to pronounce why were you
first interested in chess what got you
into chess um you know I think it's that
my brother start playing chess you know
when I was very young I was probably
about four years old and he started
taking lessons and he got very good very
quickly and
[Music]
because of that I've surrounded a lot
and then when my mother remarried my
stepfather sanella where a mantra who of
course is a very prominent chess coach
in New York City um through that I just
ended up at a lot of different
restaurants and so just being around it
I got interested in navigable was there
ever a point just this is just question
I'm thinking of since I've known you
since we were younger was there a point
where you wouldn't cause considering a
different career path like as you when
you were younger where you didn't want
to I mean besides I came for nine years
old and we want to beat want to play for
the Yankees I'm saying like past that
was there a point where you were a
babysitter there was a point I think
that's when I was seven 17 or 18 right
around that time in 2006 when I briefly
quit playing trust to go to go to
college um yeah and so definitely that
was the time that I considered it I mean
as far as what I was studying it would
have been political science but I'm
quite happy I didn't end up in that that
that in that messy world because I think
chess is much simpler mm-hmm chess does
have its it's dirty politics but nothing
like that right hi yeah I'm just curious
because I we've known each other forever
I've never asked you that and do you do
you um was there something that happened
during that time in your life were you
where you decided to was there a
particular tournament you had or a
particular experience would anybody say
anything that changed your mind about
what what you were doing regarding your
professional chess career um well I
don't think it was anything anyone did
but I think it was I was in November
2006 I was towards the end of the first
semester at college when I chose to play
and the I think it was Liberty Bell open
it in Philadelphia over the Thanksgiving
weekend and I really had not looked at
any chess for probably five months solid
and I went inside tournament I won that
one the event was five and a half out of
six beating I think I beat you das and
I'd be I beat one other strong
grandmaster the names not coming to me
and I think I drew a Soria
Georgia Grandmaster in last round when a
position where I probably was winning so
I think just the fact that I was able to
come back and win with what seemed like
what seemed like a pretty effortless I
mean it seemed very easy for me it kind
of just made it a lot easier come back
right you felt like okay maybe this is a
sign that I need to be I need to keep
doing this right yeah I think because it
felt so easy I didn't feel like you
grind is kind of like I mean right it
just felt it felt right got it
well cool good to know a little more
about the US Champion and rule number
three a car oh thank you so much for
doing this today thank you from thank
you for supply
minding me of where I belong in my
putting me in my place with some awesome
chess and it's all good just just play
play play the best moves don't try and
get creative and clutter and think that
I actually blunder it's okay you don't
have to pretend we know I'm beyond help
I'm beyond help you don't even have to
come no but seriously everyone follow at
GM a carro on Twitter make sure you look
for everything he's doing what's your
next big chess event where all your fans
can can what look for you playing right
so my next my next big event will be the
feed at Grand Prix and hunting
Montesquieu Russia and from May I think
made 13 to 27 so that's the fourth and
final event of the feeder Grand Prix
cycle so hopefully if I do well if all
five of the candidates okay
well best of luck to you and everybody
here will be rooting for you the car
well thank you so much for grace today
thanks no problem any time I have to
have a great evening
you too all right well that was
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura
joining all of us here everybody and
we're gonna go ahead and bring the show
to a close wrap this thing up as they
say Hikaru is awesome and really cool of
him to stick around and answer those
questions for everybody who got to ask
him on Twitter if you have other
questions you can maybe ask them
directly to a car on Twitter and maybe
he can sometimes get to those but we
wish him the best of luck we hope
everybody learned something today and
you enjoyed it and have fun get back to
your Saturday evening stay safe stay
classy and we'll see you around on chess
calm everybody